ça fait plaisir franchement j'aime
beaucoup je suis très content qu'il soit
là mais vous pouvez dire que c'est une
mauvaise idée je m'en rappelle à
l'époque on a dit plein de fois qu'il y
avait des chroniqueurs c'était une
mauvaise idée
alors bonne idée ou mauvaise idée
l'arrivée de jean pascal dans touche pas
à 20 dans touche pas à mon poste l'année
prochaine et pour l'instant donc c'est
que du qui je vais donner la parole car
je suis extrêmement galon mais un
entendu je vais donner la parole on
vient et ma chérie à jean mi bon ben
c'est pourquoi aurait il est pourtant
allé du sud-ouest et 2c je kiffe le sud
ouest
mais déjà il a une réputation qui le
précède et réputation de branleurs et je
pèse mes mots
voilà il se trouve que dans cette
émission la voyait président est soigné
mais correct il a une réputation va
c'est pas grave est pas mort il
travaille pas beaucoup et ça ça me gêne
terriblement vous vous trompez il
travaille peut-être certainement puisque
vous sais pas ce qu'on va dire j'espère
que l'effet de prouveront le contraire
mais voilà je trouve que voilà ici ça
rigole beaucoup mais avant on ne voit
pas beaucoup mis énormément de travail
et ça vaut le savoir aux autres de se
passer de mauvaises idées ces mauvaises
idées aussi parce que déjà c'est un beau
gosse ça j'avoue il est beau gosse mais
deux beaux gosses dans l'émission je
parle de vous évidemment me parlez-vous
je pense sinon moi je parle de retrouver
la part de louga ma de loup alpha dans
la meute
voilà vous êtes dominant jean-pascal
j'ai peur qu'il soit passé à les modèles
non parce que c'est mon damien traille
avril et il est très sympa mais je joue
on a déjà parlé avant l'émission et
faire du golf et biarritz et c'est alors
l'ipad 2 heureusement il s'appelle
lacoste et jpeg papa de ma folle quand
même s'il a causé un crocodile et
crocodile c'est connu voire une grande
gueule et il coule
[Rires]
moi je peux plus vous plairait je peux
plus alors allez-y lll veulent alors la
mode puis tout à l'heure elle ça fait
deux heures que lève la main même de
même pour rien dire oui à l'isi ont rien
dire allez-y normalisé alors
professionnellement parlant moi je pense
qu'on lui a toujours proposé des rôles
qui n'ont pas abouti parce que je pense
qu'on n'a pas su le cerner et vous vous
êtes le premier à bien cerner les gens
et à savoir ce qu'on peut faire ou non
avec ça fait dix ans que j'ai passés je
pense que jean pascal il est parfait
pour cette émission et je pense que ça
va justement aboutir parce que vous avez
vu qu'il avait vu qu'ils avaient laden
d'art cas là il a déjà commencé
achèveront toutes les nanas dans les
couloirs il ya sa femme qui regarde donc
c'est obligé il a fallu tour pucistes
discuter avec lui des frères fidel et
très amoureux mais oui oui non mais il
est très amoureux quand je dis s'ébranle
dans la franchise en elle par des
avalanches et d'électricité à venir y
avait quelqu'un moi moi moi moi il y
avait là il y avait delphi la styliste
chercher du du courant il a fait j'adore
elle a pris le veut la mettre là voilà
c'est tout à la rigolade je parle des
choses bien sûr et voilà donc c'est la
bonne humeur exactement réunis dans le
passé les compétences qu'il a acquis
seront bonnes pour cette émission